[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 7 février
bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez sur tv
78 édition spéciale ce soir largement
consacré à la neige et ses répercussions
dans le département tout de suite les
titres de cette édition les yvelines
toujours en alerte orange neige verglas
les intempéries cause depuis hier de
lourdes perturbations sur le territoire
des automobilistes bloqués la nuit
dernière sur les axes et des transports
en commun stopper ou au ralenti et des
services fermés et des événements
annulés ont fait le point sur toutes les
conséquences tout au long de cette
édition est sur le point le point aussi
sur la météo qui risque d'être et
glacial dans les prochaines heures
depuis cette nuit la préfecture des
yvelines a activé son centre
opérationnel départemental pour
coordonner les opérations de secours sur
le territoire notamment celles sur les
routes où la circulation reste très
difficile et dangereuse cet après midi à
léa gendarmes étaient à pied d'oeuvre à
beaune elle nous recevons d'ailleurs sur
ce plateau le capitaine eddie hicks
lebon commandant de l'escadron de
sécurité routière des yvelines et puis
le reste de l'actualité avec le début du
festival babel sky dédié à la bande
dessinée avec moi sur ce plateau donc le
capitaine et dicks lebon bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes le commandant de l'escadron de
sécurité routière des yvelines vous
restez avec nous tout au long de cette
édition verra notamment comment vos
services sont mobilisés pendant à cette
période et je le disais donc un épais
manteau blanc sur les yvelines les
flocons sont tombés en abondance cette
nuit dans le département vous vous êtes
réveillés avec 12 à 20 cm de neige
localement un record de longue date
battu l alerte orange est maintenue
toute cette nuit sur le territoire l'un
des plus touchés par les intempéries
le plan neige verglas en ile de france
est passé au niveau 3 la préfecture des
yvelines laisse actifs son centre
opérationnel départemental pour
coordonner les opérations de secours
dans le département une véritable
pagaille également sur les routes
franciliennes citadins a enregistré hier
soir un pic de bouchons à 7 139 km de
nombreuses automobilistes sont restés
figés dans
les yvelines sur les autoroutes a12 à
13,86 et également sur les nationales 10
12 et 118 près de 500 personnes ont été
accueillies dans des centres d'urgence
comme vous le voyez ici à vélizy mais
également au chesnay à plaisir ou encore
à bois d'arcy vous l'avez compris de
grosses perturbations depuis 24 heures
dans le département pour certains à la
neige a rimé avec cauchemar
d'autres ont profité de la météo pour
s'amuser
résumé de ces dernières heures avec
aurélie rose patrick jacques de dixmude
et nicolas kirillovitch avancée de
quelques centimètres pour ensuite se
retrouver à l'arrêt pendant plusieurs
minutes
voici la situation vécue hier soir par
des milliers d'automobilistes yvelinois
trois quatre cinq heures voire plus pour
parcourir quelques dizaines de
kilomètres seulement
certains ont même dû abandonner leur
voiture pour passer la nuit dans des
centres d'hébergement d'urgence
et si ce matin vous aviez choisi
l'option transports en commun pour vous
rendre au travail
voici ce que l'on pouvait entendre
saison
depuis
7h30 chitour donc c'est gagné bah on
attend ibère qui devrait dans 5 minutes
normalement il n'y a plus aucun bus qui
circulent il n'y a pas de taxi alors car
l'art et qui ce faisant il ya peu avant
midi et a du coup c'est un peu le seul
moyen qu'on avait situation compliquée
aussi ce matin pour ceux qui voulaient
malgré la neige prendre leur voiture
[Musique]
on va essayer de trouver une solution
mais bon pour l'instant c'est difficile
pour rendre cette situation la moins
pénible au possible les agents des queen
de 50 en yvelines sont à pied d'oeuvre
comme ici à montigny le bretonneux ou
encore à maurepas dans le cadre du plan
neige de la ville les agents sont
mobilisés depuis 5 heures ce matin il
des guerres les axes principaux et
secondaires pour faire en sorte que le
quotidien ne s'arrête pas et j'en
appelle aussi la responsabilité des
propriétaires parce qu'ils peuvent aussi
d'aimer g devant chez eux jusqu'à un
mètre cinquante
oh pas de leur porte et pareil pour les
commerçants ont fait des appels aux voix
l'a pas le civic
donc je pense que c'est une démarche
collective pour réussir de passer cet
épisode neigeux la manière la plus
simple possible
cet épais manteau blanc devrait tenir
encore plusieurs jours
une galère diront certains d'autres
préfèrent relativiser et profiter des
charmes de ce paysage de montagne on va
se promener un petit peu on va se
balader entre profiter quoi et c'était
prévu de ne pas travailler
et puis va du coup bas pour pour les
petits va se fait des heureux
et on remercie d'ailleurs les yvelines
où ils ont été nombreux à nous faire
parvenir leur image aujourd'hui vous
pouvez continuer à nous les envoyer ces
images via notre compte twitter tv 78
capital fixe le beau juste côté des
gendarmes les dernières 24 heures elles
ont elles ont ressemblé à quoi alors
c'était depuis la mi-journée une forte
mobilisation des services de gendarmerie
sous l'égide de la préfecture à
versailles nous avons mobilisé 200
gendarmes qui sont répartis sur
l'ensemble du département qui portent
assistance aux automobilistes sur les
axes routiers ou qui vont faire du
renseignement ce soit
avec les hélicoptères qui ont été
mobilisés pour voir la fluidité des axes
ou avec les mobiles de satory qui sont
intervenus sur les axes comme la 118
pour dégager les évacuer des personnes
hier soir mais on verra tout à l'heure
aussi une opération de secours à bonnel
notamment avec une aide apportée à un
poids lourd on verra ça tout à leurs
nombreux impacts des intempéries donc
dans le département vous avez pu le voir
dans le sujet précédent bon soir mélanie
poquet de la rédaction de tv 60,18 les
difficultés mélanie vont continuer
notamment dans les transports
alors déjà une information et sur les
transports scolaires et périscolaires ne
seront pas assurées demain dans
l'ensemble du département ce sont aussi
la patience va être le maître mot la
sncf se transmet annonce des
perturbations jusqu'à 23h50 sur la ligne
rennes
l'ensemble de la mini concernés pour la
ligne e -u la situation est encore plus
complexe
évitez de l'emprunter pour la ligne c le
trafic et réorganiser mais des
perturbations sont à prévoir jusqu'à 23
heures
une situation qui ne s'améliore pas
également du côté des bus ou alors parce
que pour le réseau stibus il ya une
reprise partielle en début d'après midi
salle ont concerné les lignes 400 1 414
qu'elle fonde 7 418 ou encore 465 cette
circulation très délicate était garanti
jusqu'à jusqu'en fin d'après-midi et les
équipes espère un rétablissement de la
circulation sur les mines demain à
partir de 7 heures du côté de fébus le
service de bus desservant versa et saint
cyr et vélizy le service est ralenti
une dizaine de lignes fonctionnent et
les informations précises sont à
retrouver sur le site internet alors à
cause des intempéries mais la ligne
nombreux services également des
événements
ne ne sont pas en mesure pardon d'être
rassurés et c'est le cas notamment sur
le territoire de 50 ans dès lors des
événements et des services vous l'avez
dit ce que les poubelles n'ont pas été
vidée aujourd'hui pas de collecte de
déchets sur l'agglomération s'est remis
à plus tard du côté de l'uv escudé cours
et des partielles ont été annulés de
nombreux rendez-vous sont aussi annulés
c'est le cas de la conférence qui était
organisée ce soir par le pavé du canal
avec jean jouzel et pierre larrouturou
ou encore les 40 ans du conservatoire de
plaisir qui devait fêter ce soir au
théâtre
coluche la commune et dont on vous
parlait hier dans le journal toujours un
plaisir à les équipes enseignantes
pourrait proposer un accueil minimale à
raison d'un ou deux enseignants pour les
écoles fontaine frappy et prévert
maternelle aucun accueil ne semble pour
le moment possible et les écoles et
accueils périscolaires d'elancourt eux
seront ouverts mais bien sûr comme
beaucoup de communes il est recommandé
aux parents qui le peuvent de garder
leurs enfants à voisins bretons ne
notamment l'atelier d'enfants au sein de
l'école des pépinières sera fermé jeudi
matin les différents services sont sur
le terrain mélanie mais nous aussi on
peut on peut améliorer un petit peu la
circulation et notamment celle des
piétons s'était précisée dans le sujet
juste avant par le maire de north pas
penser à déneiger devant chez vous en
déblayant jusqu'au trottoir
vous pouvez aussi salée ou sablé en cas
de verglas et justement si vous habitez
à maurepas des bacs sont à votre
disposition dans plusieurs quartiers de
la ville et la liste est bien sûr
disponible sur le site de la ville
le verglas devrait faire son apparition
cette nuit grégory météo france annonce
notamment des températures pouvant
atteindre -5 degrés et débrouillarde et
brouillards givrants la météo je vous en
disiez justement deux mots merci à
mélanie pour cette chronique la météo
qui est au centre de toutes les
attentions je vous disais en début
d'émission à les yvelines sont toujours
placés ce soir et pour la nuit en
vigilance orange neige verglas alors
comment la situation va-t-elle évoluer
dans les prochaines heures nicolas
kirilow vite c'est patrick jacques de
dixmude se sont rendus dans les locaux
du centre départemental de météo france
à trappes
beaucoup se sont fait surprendre par la
météo c'est 48 24 dernières heures
l'occasion de faire le point pour savoir
ce qu'il va en être pour demain jeudi
puis la fin de semaine nous sommes ici
s'ils attrapent au centre météorologique
de météo france avec frédéric mizrahi
qui est prévisionnistes bonjour fodec
dites nous quel va être aujourd'hui
enfin pour ce soir et pour cette nuit
les les prévisions de météo france est
ce que ça va continuer le froid est-ce
que ça va s'aggraver alors écoutez
on a actuellement les dernières petites
chutes de neige sur le sud du
département le sud des yvelines et
le risque qui nous occupe c'est ce soir
et cette nuit surtout la baisse des
températures qui risque d'être
importante surtout s'il ya des
éclaircies nocturnes
parce que nous avons des sols qui sont
très enneigé et lorsqu'on a des
éclaircies nocturnes avec un sol enneigé
ça augmente beaucoup la déperdition de
chaleur et on a des températures qui
baissent très vite donc on pourrait
avoir des températures qui descendraient
jusqu'à -5 à moins huit degrés voire
pourquoi pas en cas d' écrire ces
nocturnes plus importantes jusqu'à -10
localement dans les secteurs notamment
les secteurs les plus enneigés notamment
dans l'ouest du département par exemple
on a eu jusqu'à 25 centimètres de neige
alors qu'on a eu
ailleurs sur les yvelines entre 10 et 20
centimètres globalement du coup si je si
je si on comprend bien il ya plus besoin
forcément de craindre aujourd'hui la
neige
il faut surtout craindre le froid se
parer au froid voilà puisqu'on a quand
même malgré tout des résidus de neige
qui sont présents sur les chaussées et
donc avec ce froid qui va arriver très
vite cette nuit ces résidus vents vont
geler et donc ça va favoriser des
risques de verglas important forcément
des routes compliqué pour les
automobilistes des transports aussi que
d'être fragilisée est-ce que ça ça va
perdurer aussi vendredi je crois savoir
aussi que que la neige va revenir
vendredi on a une période d'accalmie
donc pour ce jeudi donc après donc les
gelées du matin on a une journée assez
calme jeudi une journée de transition
et puis malheureusement vendredi une
nouvelle perturbation qui arrive le
matin à une perturbation neigeuse alors
des neiges qui seront moins importante
que ce qu'on a eu
la nuit dernière et hier mais des neiges
quand même qu'ils pourraient apporter
3,5 cm de neige avec un retour qui sera
très faible et insuffisant pour pour
faire fondre cette neige
donc ça c'est des centimètres qui vont
se rajouter à ce qu on a déjà
actuellement sur nos sur nos sols
donc voilà encore un épisode neigeux et
puis ensuite de nouveau du froid pour la
nuit de vendredi à samedi un froid c'est
marquer de nouveau et puis un léger
redoux dans la journée de samedi mais
qui sera pas très important et un
week-end qui aura un redoute finalement
assez léger pas très important donc lui
avec encore des gelées nocturnes pour
avoir un rendu un peu plus sensible il
faudra attendre mercredi battant
mercredi prochain donc dans presque une
semaine donc
donc ça s'annonce sassano curieux comme
le redoute voilà donc c'est assez lent
et malgré tout on reste dans une période
finalement assez hivernale donc voila
vous l'aurez vous l'aurez compris les
prochaines 24-48 heures sont encore très
compliqué le week-end aussi probablement
il va lui falloir s'armer de patience
sur les routes et dans les transports en
commun et nicolas kirillovitch et
patrick jacques de dixmude aux moyens
techniques depuis le centre
départemental de météo france à trappes
pour gérer la crise la préfecture des
yvelines a donc activé son centre
opérationnel départemental il coordonne
l'ensemble des opérations sur le
territoire
à noter notamment une assistance de la
croix rouge hier pour distribuer sur les
routes boissons nourriture et
couvertures aux naufragés naufragés de
la route les pompiers ont utilisé
également leur matériel de
désincarcération pour découper une
glissière de sécurité sur l'a86 afin de
permettre aux véhicules de passer de
basculer de l'autre côté de la kz
opérations menées aussi par les forces
de l'ordre notamment par les gendarmes
cet après midi à bonnel dans le sud
yvelines camy lambert et mélanie pau qui
a été sur place il est 15h à bonnel les
hommes de la gendarmerie de
saint-arnoult viennent d'autoriser deux
camions à repartir ils avaient été
déroutés il hier soir de l'autoroute
comment dans des situations comme
celle-ci vous en connaissez
régulièrement annoncée des épisodes
neigeux comme celui ci est assez
exceptionnel effectivement puisque mes
gendarmes sont mobilisés depuis hier
environ 15 heures et ont travaillé une
grande partie de la nuit
effectivement pour différentes missions
ça représente combien d'hommes sur le
terrain à peu près alors cette nuit par
exemple où l'épisode neigeux a été le
plus important
trente militaires de la gendarmerie du
sud yvelines a travaillé sur ce secteur
il est 15h face et l'assistance
peut-être véhicule et terminé quelle est
la suite pour vous avec les températures
qui vont baisser cette nuit oui
effectivement
la mission est quasiment rempli mais
nous restons vigilants pour nous sommes
toujours mobilisés bien entendu pour
nous assurer de la fiabilité des axes
des principaux axes de communication
dans tout le sud yvelines et donc même
dans tout le département
les militaires ont effectué une
quinzaine d'interventions depuis le
début de la nuit des interventions
possibles grâce aux agriculteurs aux
communes mais aussi des pompiers comme
ceux de rambouillet
la main
lieutenant vous venez de faire une
intervention que ce qui s'est passé
alors un poids lourd s'est retrouvé
piégé donc sur la commune de rochefort
en yvelines dans une pente
il s'est retrouvé piégé il a glissé
s'est retrouvée bloquée donc contre un
poteau un arbre on vous lance dégager le
poids lourd a percé son réservoir de
carburant
donc on s'est retrouvé face à un risque
de pollution du reiki et est située
juste au niveau du pont loi donc l'idée
de manoeuvre était de pomper le
carburant qui se rester dans le
réservoir environ 700 litres est donc là
on a un attentes des pompes pour
réaliser la manoeuvre pour pouvoir
évacuer le poids lourd ensuite sur un un
garage pour lui indiquer ce temps là on
s'en doute bien les pompiers vous êtes
appelés pour de l'assistance à la
personne des voitures qui perdent le
contrôle et ça aussi c'est une mission
peut-être qu'on connaît moins oui alors
là on n'est pas sûr de ce que la
personne mais sur deux
moi plutôt protéger l'environnement
d'une pollution donc c'est ce qui fait
partie intégrante de nos missions
puisqu'on est en campagne donc les
délais de route
vu les états de l'état des routes
aujourd'hui est encore augmenté donc
c'est ce qui nous fait perdre énormément
de temps
cette intervention aura duré à la
journée le verglas est attendu pour la
nuit les secours conseille de ne pas
prendre son véhicule est avec moi
toujours en plateau le capitaine eddie
hicks le beau jeu rappelle vous êtes le
commandant de l'escadron de sécurité
routière des yvelines pour la
gendarmerie nationale on imagine à
événement exceptionnel moyens
exceptionnels vous en disiez de mots
tout à l'heure dans une telle crise les
services de la gendarmerie sont
pleinement mobilisés pour que ça fait on
a l'habitude de mobiliser rapidement les
forces humaines et des moyens matériels
depuis la mi-journée hier 200 gendarmes
son département se déployer sur le
terrain et ils portent assistance aux
automobilistes sur tous les axes et
qu'est-ce que vous avez constaté là
depuis ces dernières 24 heures beaucoup
beaucoup d'accidents de pannes sur sur
les routes
lorsqu'on a constaté c'est déjà une
augmentation considérable des appels
téléphoniques 4 plus d'appels avec c'est
les circonstances météorologiques au
niveau des interventions
notre mission principale c'est de faire
respecter les interdictions de circuler
pour les poids lourds des pieds par la
préfecture et ensuite de porter
assistance à l'ensemble des
automobilistes qu'on se le dise à un
centre opérationnel départemental qui
est piloté par la préfecture est ce que
les gendarmes y participent également
tout à fait on a deux militaires qui
sont détachés au centre opérationnel à
versailles et coordonne l'ensemble des
opérations sur département alors nos
journalistes camille lambert et mélanie
peau qu'elles ont dit dans le sujet
juste avant il ya eu aussi une aide et
des agriculteurs sur les routes avec
leurs tracteurs ils ont pu aider vos
services tout à fait nous n'avons pas de
moyens spécialisés pour dégager des
véhicules dans ces conditions météo ont
demandé l'aide aux agriculteurs avec
leurs tracteurs qu'ils ont toutes les
rangs et qui peuvent dégager les
véhicules
on rappelle donc on a vu une opération
pour dégager un véhicule telles quelles
peuvent être les autres types
d'opérations dans
dans cette situation alors ce qu'on a
fait c'est on a mobilisé des forces de
gendarmerie mobile de satory et ils sont
intervenus avec des camions militaires
sur la 118 ils ont évacué six cents
personnes hier soir on utilise aussi le
moyen hélico qui permettent de faire un
point sur la fluidité sur les axes ça
permet d'aller très vite sur certains
points de de pouvoir
alors on va pas porter assistance
acquise il y croit et ça permet de
renseigner les autorités et à la
situation alors les autorités ont
largement appelé hier à ne pas utiliser
son véhicule a différé également ses
déplacements au pouvoir prendre les
allées transports en commun quand on
voit le nombre de voitures qui ont été
n'offre âgées ont utilisé le terme de
naufragés bloqués cette nuit sur sur les
axes et on voit aussi les difficultés
dans encore ce matin on peut on peut
dire que les ces directives n'ont pas
été suivis malheureusement non le
conseil numéro un c'est de réduire au
minimum ses déplacements en véhicules et
les limiter aux situations d'urgence
malheureusement il ya des véhicules qui
sont sur les routes et ils constituent
des obstacles pour les autres usagers de
la route
alors pour les poids lourds vous disiez
un arrêté qui a été dit est dictée pour
interdire la circulation aux poids
lourds ça sera donc deux arrêtés le
premier concerne les poids lourds donc
interdiction pour eux de rentrer dans
paris et doivent contourner ou être
stockées sur l'a13 la nationale 12 sur
l'a10 et le second point ce sont les
transports scolaires qui est interdite
aujourd'hui on a vu des images depuis ce
matin deux poids lourds notamment bloqué
sur l'a10 est ce qu'il ya encore des
opérations actuellement qui se poursuit
et des opérations de pour dégager ces
poils au c'est ça il y avait 600 camions
qui étaient sur l'a10 avec la fenêtre
météo de cet après midi ils ont été
autorisés à reprendre la direction de
paris mais à 20h ce soir et vont être
bloqués si son corps sur l'autoroute
alors on l'a vu aussi dans le sujet
météo
l'épisode de neige qui est en train de
se terminer là ça va laisser place au
verglas le le gel cette nuit qu'est ce
que vous avez envie de dire ce soir aux
automobilistes et ce qu'ils doivent
encore différer leur déplacement des
siens au maximum en tout yade de ne pas
prendre la voiture c'est ça trois
conseils le premier c'est de ne pas se
déplacer avec un véhicule personnel
c'est sauf si nécessaire mais vraiment
extrême urgence
le deuxième c'est d'anticiper son
déplacement c'est à dire prévoir des
délais supplémentaires d'équiper son
vécu 6 est encore temps avec des pneus
hiver neige avec des chaînes et enfin si
on est sur la route adapter sa vitesse
et faire anticipé des sondages d'accord
oui c'est ce que j'avais à j'allais vous
demandez way succion du coup on est
obligé de prendre la route et c'est
d'adapter sa conduite qu'elle quels
conseils tels quels réflexes il faut
avoir sur sur la route alors si la
voiture patine il faut éviter de rouler
en première mais plutôt en seconde
d'accord ça sera plus simple
rouler avec des voitures à des feux de
croisement pour être bien vu et pour
bien voir ce qui se passe et avant une
vitesse ce très modéré dernière question
est ce que vous savez ce qui vous attend
là dans l'est dans les prochaines heures
voilà c'est l'événement météo avec
peut-être du verglas ce soir et demain
matin ce qui va poser encore des
problèmes de circulation sont donc merci
avec l'année dick lebeau bavard est avec
nous voici le rappel commandant de
l'escadron de sécurité routière des
yvelines pour la gendarmerie nationale
et pour plus d'informations sur la
situation
les dernières informations dans les
yvelines je vous invite à consulter le
site internet de la préfecture des
yvelines
[Musique]
et dans le reste de l'actualité de la
culture la bd ne craint pas la neige
aujourd'hui a démarré à saint quentin en
yvelines
le festival bubble ce cas il est dédié à
la bande dessinée
et pour cette deuxième édition le thème
donné c'est le manga marylène yapi chez
nous après le succès de la première
édition les médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines veulent
transformer l'essai le mois de la bande
dessinée devenir le festival bubble sky
et l'agglomération adopte la culture
japonaise du manga sur la durée du
festival
il y à des expositions des ateliers de
dessin dans les médiathèques vous pouvez
retrouvez la programmation sur le site
internet des médiathèques
on reçoit aussi des portraitistes manga
qui peuvent venir vous croquez façon
manga dans plusieurs médiathèque de
saint quentin et la programmation riche
des cinémas entre manga film japonais
les cinémas indépendants se sont donc
ajoutés aux festivités en créant même
l'exploit le grenier à sel est l'un des
rares cinéma français a diffusé le
célèbre manga akira le 24 février pour
jouer le jeu jusqu'au bout la
médiathèque du canal a transformé son
auditorium en manga qui ça ces salons de
thé japonais conçu pour y lire ce manga
tranquillement mais avant de profiter de
la vue sur le canal enneigées petit tour
par l'exposition
on a aussi la chance de travailler avec
le conservatoire des arts de
montigny-le-bretonneux est donc cette
année le professeur de bande dessinée
monsieur jean pierre a fait travailler
ses élèves autour du manga à notre
sollicitation
voilà et donc du coup et on a une très
jolie exposition sous forme de stickers
de deux planches que compte travailler
ses élèves donc de 6 à 77 ans le
festival buzz sky soutiendra jusqu'au 4
mars dont toutes les médiathèques et les
cinémas indépendants de l'agglomération
depuis 1969 l'école nationale supérieure
d'architecturé officie à versailles elle
forme ses étudiants dans des bâtiments
classés monuments historiques ils sont à
la petite écurie du roi de la
maréchalerie sur le domaine du château
de versailles l'école organise
samedi dernier ces portes ouvertes
marylène iapichino et nicolas bendriss
l'école nationale supérieure
d'architecturé de versailles et ses 1200
étudiants prépare déjà sa rentrée 2018
avec une journée portes ouvertes pour
présenter ses enseignements et informer
sur les différentes facettes du métier
d'architecte donc à travailler en agence
pour faire du projet en agence on peut
travailler dans des collectivités on
peut travailler on peut écrire sur
l'architecturé de critique
d'architecturé on peut enseigner
l'architecturé il ya il ya énormément de
débouchés et de deux manières de
pratiquer larchitecture l'admission à
l'école se fait sur dossier et entretien
trois années de licence sont communes à
tous les étudiants les futurs
d'architectes ont ensuite deux ans pour
se spécialiser suivant leurs préférences
en master enfin c'est très large en fait
les études darchy touche à la sociologie
mais aussi à la construction à l'art
plastique au droit à la philosophie ya
vraiment beaucoup de cours donc c'est
très complet et on a une journée par
semaine qui est banalisée pour s'occuper
uniquement du projet qui est le
coefficient le plus important don c'est
là où on fait on crée nos maquettes et
nos plans nos coupes vraiment les
documents les plus complets durant la
journée les étudiants pour présenter
leur projet très créatif à la hauteur de
leurs ambitions
bon soit pour les débouchés ces deux
dans un premier temps peut-être joindre
une agence pour gagner de l'expérience
et ensuite c'est de créer mon agence 83
% des étudiants de l'école de versailles
trouvent un emploi dans l'année de
l'obtention de leur diplôme
et avant de refermer ce journal on vous
rappelle les principales informations
concernant la neige l' alerte orange
neige verglas est maintenue ce soir et
pour la nuit prochaine dans les yvelines
une nuit qui s'annonce très froide avec
des températures négatives prudence donc
de mise je rajoute que lé service de
ramassage scolaire et périscolaire ne
seront pas assurées demain les communes
qui conseille aux parents d'éviter au
maximum de d'emmener leurs enfants à
l'école demain concernant les transports
un des perturbations encore à prévoir
jusqu'à ce soir 23h 50 pour les lignes n
ai eu du train et du transilien et les
lignes de bus 1 qui reprennent peu à peu
leur leur trafic
janot à cette heure le journal est
enregistrée à 18h25 les informations
peuvent bien sûr évolué je vous invite à
consulter régulièrement
ces deux sites internet le site internet
de la préfecture des yvelines et
également pour les températures le site
de météo france
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
spéciale est à revoir sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
78 une nouvelle fois prudents ce soir
dans les yvelines et et bon courage à
ceux qui sont sur le chemin du retour
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]